بالنسبة لأولئك الذين نفذوا هذا الهجوم
وكذلك أي شخص يتمنى الأذى لأمريكا ،
اعلم أن
هذا لن نسامح
ولن ننسى
أننا سنطاردك
ونجعلك تدفع ،
ولن يردعنا
الإرهابيون ولن ندعهم يوقفون مهمتنا نحن
سأستمر في الإخلاء ،
لقد أمرت قائدي أيضًا
بوضع خطط
تشغيلية لضرب قيادة ومرافق تنظيم الدولة الإسلامية ،
وسنرد بقوة ودقة
في الوقت الذي نختاره في المكان الذي نختاره في
لحظة من اختيارنا
، إليك ما تحتاج إلى معرفته
لن ينتصر إرهابيو داعش هؤلاء ،
وسوف ننقذ الأمريكيين ،
وسوف نحصل على حلفائنا الأفغان
، وسوف تستمر مهمتنا في
أمريكا ولن يتم ترهيبها ،
ولا يوجد دليل حتى الآن على
أنه تم إخباري نتيجة لذلك من قبل
أي من قادتنا في  المجال
الذي حدث فيه
تواطؤ
بين طالبان وداعش
وتنفيذ
ما حدث اليوم
سواء أمام الفندق أو أمام ما
يتوقع استمراره.